[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen was an diesem Samstag im
Sport passiert ist erfahren sie von
Norbert König ja genau Viertelstunde
ungefähr guten Abend unsere
nachrichten-team
Frankreich kommt nicht zur Ruhe nach
erneuten Krawallen sagt Präsident macron
seinen Staatsbesuch in Deutschland ab
auf dem Weg zu mir Gerechtigkeit mehr
als 30 Jahre nach der Einheit wird der
Rentenwert in Ost und West angeglichen
auf der Suche nach der dunklen Materie
Europa schickt das Weltraumteleskop
Euklid in Salz
[Musik]
denn Frankreich von einem Polizisten
erschossene 17-Jährige nach hell ist
heute beerdigt worden auch in der
vergangenen Nacht kam es landesweit
wieder zu Unruhen und sie könnten
weitergehen Präsident macron hat daher
kurzfristig sein ab morgen geplanten
Staatsbesuch in Deutschland verschoben
von einer verheerenden Bilanz sprechen
die Behörden seit Dienstag sollen
landesweit rund 2400 Menschen
festgenommen worden sein 200 Polizisten
sein verletzt und mehr als 2000
Fahrzeuge angezündet worden dazu ging
viele Gebäude in Flammen auf dutzende
Geschäfte wurden geplündert anne-
besonders heftig trifft es dieses Mal
Marseille Plünderungen zerschlagene
Scheiben in der Innenstadt Anwohner und
Händler sind schockiert über die
ungebremste willkürliche Gewalt viele
stehen nun vor dem Nichts
ziegenkatastrophen es ist eine
Katastrophe ich habe so etwas in meinem
Leben nicht gesehen mir fehlen die Worte
ich habe doch auch eine Familie zu
versorgen was sollen wir nur machen
wenn man will dass ich etwas ändert dann
soll man das bei denen fordern die dafür
verantwortlich sind man fackelt doch
nicht einfach das Hab und Gut der
anderen ab
die Randalierer sind zum Teil sehr jung
13 14 Jahre alt landesweit gibt es mehr
als 1.300 Festnahmen und auch wenn diese
Bilder aus nach say eine extreme
Gewaltbereitschaft zeigen erklärte der
Innenminister am frühen Morgen
generell kann man sagen dass die
Ausschreitungen weniger heftig waren als
in den Nächten zuvor und dann appelliert
die Regierung an die Verantwortung von
tiktok snapchat und Co die Brutalität
der Bilder und Inhalte würde viele
Jugendliche anheizen die Polizei
beobachtet die Entwicklung mit Sorge
was ich geändert hat ist allein schon
deren Ausrüstung und der Wille sogar zu
töten sie wollen wirklich Polizisten
töten und Feuerwehrleute sie greifen die
staatlichen Institutionen an
Kindergärten Schulen öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel und Behörden es gibt für
sie keine Regeln mehr
der Tod des Jugendlichen der am
Nachmittag hin und her beigesetzt wurde
ist nur der Auslöser schon lange gibt es
eine große Unzufriedenheit in den
Vorstädten die Gründe dafür sind
vielschichtig und daher wird es nicht
leicht die Unruhen nun wieder
einzudämmen Justiz und Polizei wurden
mit zusätzlichen Mitteln ausgestattet
doch in Marseille wie in vielen Orten
haben sie Angst vor einer neuen Nacht
der Gewalt und sichern bereits ihre
Läden
in der Unruhe hat Präsident also sein
Deutschland besucht verschoben Thomas
Walde wie ist das einzuschätzen
also Bilder eines friedlich auf der
spreeschippernden macrons während zu
Hause die Hütte brennt das wäre hier
nicht gut angekommen diese Absage ist
eine Niederlage für macron sie zeigt
dass der elisee damit rechnet dass es zu
weiteren Ausschreitungen kommt das
macron gezwungen ist zu Hause zu bleiben
um nötigenfalls auch noch selbst
einzugreifen und das relativiert dann
auch die Aussage des Innenministers die
wir gerade gesehen haben das ist doch in
der vergangenen Nacht nicht so schlimm
gewesen sei wie in den Nächten zuvor es
ist bereits das zweite Mal dass du etwas
passiert der Staatsbesuch des britischen
Königs wurde abgesagt wegen der Proteste
gegen die Rentenreform und so werden
zwei Staatsbesuche zu Symbolen für die
Lage in Frankreich und für Makros
Handlungsfähigkeit danke für diese
Einordnung Thomas Walde in Paris
nach zehn Jahren wird ja die UN-Mission
in Mali beendet auch die deutschen
Soldaten und Soldaten werden bis Ende
des Jahres aus dem westafrikanischen
Land abziehen deutlich früher als
geplant darauf sah die Bundeswehr
eingestellt zumal die Rückverlegung seit
Wochen vorbereitet werde und bereits
laufe sagte dazu jetzt die
werbeauftragte des Bundestages eV
verhügel dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland
gute Nachricht für die rund 21 Millionen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner in Deutschland
ab heute gibt es mehr Geld die Renten
steigen im Westen und sogar etwas
stärker im Osten damit gilt knapp 33
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung
erstmals ein gleicher Rentenwert
bedeutet ostdeutsche Rentnerin und
Rentner bekommen künftig bei
vergleichbarer Erwerbsbiografie die
gleiche Rente wie Menschen im Westen wie
das ankommt berichtet Cornelia
was werdet ihr denn machen wenn ihr dann
nach der Rentenerhöhung so ein Haufen
Kohle mehr haben beim Leipziger
seniorenkabarett sportvögel ist die
Rente ein emotionales Dauerthema die
Ehrenamtlichen Darsteller allesamt
selbst Rentner treffen den Nerv ihrer
Zuschauer
das Thema Rente ist natürlich etwas was
unser Publikum auch ganz stark
interessiert denn oft sind es Leute im
älteren Lebensbereich die keine anderen
Einnahmequellen mehr haben und keine
anderen Möglichkeiten sich das Leben
angenehm zu machen als über die Rente
jedes Jahr zum ersten Juli steigen die
Renten davon profitieren rund 21
Millionen Ruheständler im Westen steigen
die Altersbezüge in diesem Jahr um 4,39%
im Osten um 5,86 und erstmals gilt ein
einheitlicher Rentenwert ab sofort liegt
dieser deutschlandweit bei 37,60 € wir
schließen jetzt die letzte Lücke
deutsche Einheit im
Sozialgesetzgebung ist ein Jahr früher
als sogar gesetzlich vorgesehen das hat
der den die Ursache dass die Löhne zum
Glück im Osten schneller gestiegen sind
insbesondere aufgrund der Einführung des
unterhöhung des Mindestlohns und das ist
ein großer gesellschaftlicher
Fortschritt doch es bleibt dabei
insgesamt haben ostdeutsche Rentner
weniger Einkommen denn für 91% von ihnen
ist die gesetzliche Rente die einzige
Einnahme die haben dort weniger Vermögen
konnten weniger betriebliche Renten
aufbauen das alles schlägt sich dann
nieder in den niedrigen Lebensstandard
und das natürlich ein Problem dass die
Renten in Ost und West nach 33 Jahren
angepasst sind trifft in Leipzig auf
Zustimmung
bekommen Krieg 70 Euro mehr gut die
sportvögel jedenfalls verlieren ihren
Humor nicht egal wie hoch die Rente ist
und auch für alle die Bürgergeld
bekommen gibt es Neuigkeiten sie
erhalten verstärkt Zuschüsse um
Berufsabschlüsse nachzuholen oder sich
weiterzubilden außerdem werden die
Freibeträge für Erwerbstätige erhöht
Einkommen aus einem Schülerjob einer
Berufsausbildung oder einem
Freiwilligendienst sondern bis 520 Euro
gar nicht mehr auf das Bürgergeld
angerechnet werden und auch sonst ändert
sich heute zum ersten Juli einiges
pflegebeiträge
paketporto Kurzarbeitergeld das alles
haben wir für Sie zusammengefasst in der
ZDF heute App
weniger Zettelwirtschaft und Arztpraxen
und Apotheken dafür soll das ehrezept
sorgen seit heute reicht die
Versichertenkarte um es einzulösen doch
das Ehre Rezept ist bislang eher ein
Ladenhüter seit den ersten Tests vor
zwei Jahren sind gut 2,2 Millionen
elektronische Rezepte eingelöst worden
zum Vergleich im selben Zeitraum
stellten Arztpraxen rund 900 Millionen
papierrezepte aus über den neuen
digitalisierungsanlauf Petra Otto
seit heute ist der rosa Zettel ein
Auslaufmodell jetzt soll endgültig auch
in Deutschland kommen was in Schweden
oder Portugal längst Standard ist das
irrezept Ruben steht technikbegeisterter
Apotheker findet das prinzipiell prima
wenn es nur nicht so verwirrend wäre wir
haben einmal die Möglichkeit dass der
Arzt so ein Ausdruck macht mit QR-Code
tatsächlich ist eine der Wege einen
Ausdruck auf ein Stück Papier ist
Digitalisierung in Deutschland
Möglichkeit zwei man kann sich das
Rezept über eine App aufs Handy spielen
lassen mit einer PIN von der
Krankenkasse und drittens neu hinzu
kommt ab
1.7 die Möglichkeit sich das nur auf die
Karte speichern zu lassen den Schlüssel
und dann in der Apotheke einzulösen hier
sind sie längst bereit alle Geräte für
alle Varianten da aber bisher kommt kaum
jemand mit so einem Ehre Rezept die
Akzeptanz wird in den nächsten Wochen
deutlich zunehmen jetzt ist der Moment
wo das einfach gemacht werden muss wir
haben lange genug gewartet dass ihre
Zeit besonders Zeit wir sind bei der
Digitalisierung viele Jahre hinter dem
Plan das muss aufhören doch Jürgen de la
Port Hausarzt will das alte Rezept
behalten sich nicht abhängig machen von
Technik die seines Erachtens zu wenig
ausgereift ist
diese Freiwilligkeit die ist das was mir
so wichtig ist dass man das wieso
Schieberegler einführen kann und wenn es
gut ist dann machen es alle aber nicht
dieser Zwang dass ich dann das System
umstellen muss und dass ich auf einmal
die roten Rezepte die viele meiner
älteren Patienten so lieben gar nicht
mehr ausstellen kann bis Jahresende gibt
ihm der Gesundheitsminister noch Zeit
sich mit dem eRezept vertraut zu machen
kommen wir zum wohl größten
medikamentenskandal der deutschen
Nachkriegsgeschichte Contergan durch das
Beruhigungsmittel erlitten tausende
Menschen schwere körperliche Schäden
dennoch kämpfen Betroffene auch noch
Jahrzehnte später um angemessen
Entschädigungen eine staatliche Stiftung
lehnte bislang 80% der Anträge auf eine
Rente ab etwas Hoffnung macht jetzt
deine Entscheidung eines Gerichts in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Susanna
beim conterganverband Hessen der heute
sein 55-jähriges Bestehen feiert freuen
sich alle dass die Ablehnung vieler
contergan-renten juristisch überprüft
wird diejenigen die offensichtliche
Schäden durch den conterganstoff
talidomid haben wie verkürzte Arme
bekamen meistens die Rente anders als
die die etwa gehörlos sind sehbehindert
oder missgebildete innere Organe haben
Markus Stock hat nur eine Niere ist
zeugungsunfähig und hat schwere Schäden
an der Wirbelsäule sein Antrag wurde
abgelehnt die acht Ärzte die mich
begutachtet haben haben mich alle
persönlich gesehen und bestätigt dass
ich eine talido mit Schädigung habe die
beiden Ärzte die mich abgelehnt haben
nämlich die medizinische Kommission der
konnte ganz Stiftung diese haben mich
nie gesehen wir möchten eine
kontaktstiftung die auf unserer Seite
ist dass Sie unser Wohl haben wollen und
nicht wie wir auf der leben müssen gegen
uns arbeiten
durch die conterganstiftung hatte der
Staat die Haftung für die Firma
Grünenthal übernommen deren damals
rezeptfreies Medikament konnte garen
wird verantwortlich gemacht für schwere
Missbildungen von tausenden Kindern die
Anfang der 60er Jahre zur Welt kamen
später konnten die Betroffenen eine
contergan-rente beantragen doch seit
2009 hat die staatliche
conterganstiftung nur 200 von 1000
Anträgen anerkannt das UVG Münster
urteilte nun in erster Instanz dass es
bei der Stiftung wohl Verfahrensfehler
gab weil nur eine Person hauptsächlich
entschieden habe obwohl das Gesetze
vorschreibt dass sich der Vorsitzende
zusammen mit vier Ärzten an einen Tisch
setzen muss und dann gemeinsam beraten
werden muss über diesen Antrag
entschieden werden soll die konnte gar
nicht Stiftung teilt uns schriftlich mit
dass man das Urteil der zweiten Instanz
abwarten wolle und dann alle notwendigen
Maßnahmen ergreifen werde
viele Betroffene hoffen auf ein Stück
Gerechtigkeit sie fühlen sich seit
vielen Jahren im Stich gelassen
[Musik]
Spaniens Ministerpräsident Sanchez ist
in Kiew sein Besuch hat symbolische
Bedeutung denn seit heute hat Spanien
den EU-Ratsvorsitz sanchef bekräftigte
das Spanien den Beitritt der Ukraine zur
EU unterstützen werde das spanische
Regierungschef sagte mittleren und
kleinen Betrieben finanzielle
Unterstützung zu
Präsident selenski war auf dem Westen
vor die Ausbildung ukrainischer Piloten
an Kampfflugzeugen aus US-Produktion zu
verzögern noch immer gäbe es keinen
festen Termin für den Beginn des
pilotentrainings
beim schweren Unfall im Westen Kenias
sind mindestens 52 Menschen getötet
worden ein Lastwagen war am Freitagabend
von der Fahrbahn abgekommen raste in
mehrere andere Fahrzeuge und die Stände
eines belebten Marktes am Straßenrand
die Polizei befürchtet dass die Zahl der
Toten noch steigen könnte dutzende
Menschen wurden in Krankenhäuser
eingeliefert um ähnliche Unfälle zu
vermeiden will Kenias Regierung Märkte
künftig von Schnellstraßen an andere
Orte verlegen
die Niederlande waren einer der letzten
europäischen Staaten die Menschen in den
Kolonien versklavten vor 150 Jahren am 1
Juli 1873 kamen viele endlich frei nun
hat König Wilhelm Alexander bei den
Nachfahren offiziellen
ab den 16 Jahrhundert waren sie aus
Afrika nach Südamerika verschleppt
worden oft ins heutige Suriname eins
niederländische Kolonie oder auf mehrere
schätzungsweise 600.000 Menschen wurden
versklavt in Erinnerung daran wird der
erste juli als Tag der zerbrochenen
Ketten begangen
gedenken unterm Regenschirm
Entschuldigungen hörten sie schon viele
aber bislang nicht vom höchsten Mann im
Staat von daher heute stehe ich vor
ihnen als ihr König und als Teil der
Regierung bitte ich um Entschuldigung
Jubel bricht aus in Amsterdam
ich empfinde das zutiefst mit Leib und
Seele
Sklaverei die Geschichte dieses
Geschäfts wird in den Niederlanden immer
besser erforscht allein das Königshaus
verdiente daran über 500 Millionen Euro
nach heutigen Maßstäben Öl auf die
Handgelenke das steht für den Schmerz
der Ketten der 150 Jahrestag in
Amsterdams Osten hier haben Sie
verschiedene Wurzeln hier sitzen sie
Angesicht zu Angesicht
der Chor das Essen das dient dazu ein
sicheres Umfeld zu schaffen für das
schwierige Gespräch über Unterschiede
das Ergebnis ist im besten Fall ein
neues Zusammenleben die Entschuldigung
ist sozusagen der erste Schritt um zu
sagen ja das Unrecht ist passiert wir
schauen uns das an der zweite Schritt
ist dann eigentlich ja wie muss man
sozusagen jetzt Konsequenzen daran
verbinden
ob auf die Entschuldigung eine
Entschädigung folgt und wie die aussehen
könnte darüber wird in den Niederlanden
weiter gestritten
[Musik]
von der Erde nun in die Weiten des
Weltraums Bilder von unserer Milchstraße
von sogar weit entfernten Galaxien all
das haben wir irgendwie schon mal
gesehen und doch sind wir sozusagen fast
blind wenn wir ins All schauen denn das
besteht wohl zum größten Teil aus
dunkler Materie und dunkler Energie
diesen zwei großen Unbekannten
nachspüren soll ein neues e-sateleskop
Euklid vom Staat in den USA heute
Christian von Rechenberg
Spitzentechnologie auf dem Weg ins All
an Bord einer Falke neuenrakete das
euklid-teleskop der Isar das ist zwei
Tonnen schwer besteht aus zwei Modulen
eines das den Raumflug steuert und eines
das am Ziel die Aufgabe erledigt
Galaxien vermessen
[Applaus]
ist eine Mission die 10 Milliarden Jahre
in die Vergangenheit zurückblickt auf
die Entwicklung unseres Universums um
dies zu tun benötigen wir sehr sehr
empfindliche Instrumente
Kameras die Licht im sichtbaren und
unsichtbaren Bereich erfassen so
empfindlich dass spezielle
Schutzschilder montiert sind die
Sonnenstrahlen abhalten unverzichtbar
denn euklids-arbeitsplatz im All ist auf
halber Strecke zwischen Erde und Sonne
ein Ort mit perfekter Sicht auf jenen
Teil des Alls den man von der Erde aus
so präzise nicht erfassen kann
sechs Jahre lang macht eklig hier
draußen seine Aufnahmen
wir werden in diesem Zeitraum mehrere
Milliarden Galaxien abbilden woraufhin
die Wissenschaftler dann im Grunde
analysieren werden wie dunkle Materie
und dunkle Energie in unserem Universum
verteilt sind nur fünf Prozent davon
sind bisher erforscht diese Mission wird
buchstäblich Licht ins Dunkel bringen
bis das Teleskop aber an seinem
Arbeitsplatz ankommt wird es eine Weile
dauern vier Wochen ist Euklid erstmal
unterwegs zum Ziel in 1,5 Millionen
Kilometer Entfernung
und Dressur wie von einem anderen Stern
sieht man auch immer mal wieder von der
deutschen Equip und heute in Aachen gab
es ja ein Jubiläum Norbert ja den 40
Sieg einer deutschen Mannschaft beim
CHIO in Aachen und in der Einzelwertung
war die zweimalige Olympiasiegerin
Jessica von Bredow Werndl mit ihrer
vierbeinigen Begleiterin der Lehrer
nicht zu schlagen
ein Lob für der Lehrer nach einem
perfekten Tag beim größten Reitturnier
der Welt im Dressurviereck von Aachen
gelingt Jessica von Bredow Werndl auf
ihrer Stute eine Prüfung voller Anmut
und Grazia trotz kleiner Fehler
81,021 Punkte genügen den beiden im
Grand Prix Spezial zum Sieg vor der
britischen da und Nana Scott Mehrheit
aus Dänemark ich bin total dankbar ich
habe es heute ein bisschen spannender
gemacht Alter aber ersten Tag weil ich
zwei sehr teure Fehler mit eingebaut
habe aber der Lehrer gegen fantastisch
auch sind rotenberger mit Handy Isabel
Wert auf Quantas und Frederik wandres
mit Bluetooth überzeugen sie sichern
sich mit Jessica von Bredow Werndl und
der Lehrer den begehrten Sieg im
Nationen Preis
morgen ab 16:15 Uhr senden wir live aus
Aachen dann den Großen Preis der
Springreiterinnen und Springreiter der
Brite Adam jetzt hat die Auftakt Etappe
der 110 Auflage der Tour de France
gewonnen gestartet wurde zum ersten Mal
seit 1992 im Baskenland der Zieleinlauf
nach knapp viereinhalb Stunden wurde zu
einer family
der Rundkurs mit Start und Ziel in
Bilbao hat es in sich 182 Kilometer lang
3.300 Höhenmeter 10 km vor dem Ziel
zieht sich das Feld bei bis zu 20%
Steigung auseinander die Tour Favoriten
Tade pogaccia und Jonas wingo souverän
als erste oben auf dem Kotte Pik kurz
vorm Ziel setzen sich zwei Fahrer ab die
Zwillingsbrüder jetzt Adam siegt vor
Simon Gates der Brite gewinnt die
schwere Auftakt Etappe bester Deutscher
Emanuel Buchmann als 24
Ricarda Funk hat in Krakau im Kanu
Slalom zum dritten Mal in ihrer Karriere
den EM-Titel im Kajak Einzel gewonnen
die Olympiasiegerin aus Bad Neuenahr
sicherte ihren Verband damit einen
Quotenplatz für die Spiele im kommenden
Jahr in Paris und Formel 1 Weltmeister
Max Verstappen feiert seinen nächsten
Sieg mit dem Erfolg beim Sprint von
Spielberg hat er außerdem seinen
Vorsprung in der WM Gesamtwertung weiter
ausgebaut
der Niederländer gewinnt auch das kurze
24 Runden Rennen ins Spielberg damit
gehen alle acht Grand Prix und beide
Sprints an das Weltmeister-Team Red Bull
Kollege Sergio Perez erreicht Platz zwei
vor Callas science im Ferrari Nico
hürtenberg der in 189 Rennen nie die Top
3 erreichte liegt bis zur Halbzeit auf
Platz zwei verliert dann Positionen
wechselt auf Trockenreifen und holt als
Sechster am Ende drei WM Punkte mit dem
Sieg baut Verstappen seine WM-Führung
auf Perez vor dem Großen Preis Morgen
damit auf 70 Punkte aus
und das richtig lange Rennen gibt's dann
morgen dankeschön das Wetter bleibt
abwechslungsreich gleich mehr dazu von
Christa Orden das heute journal können
Sie an diesem Abend um 22:45 Uhr sehen
mit Maria tschüss
[Musik]
ja guten Abend heute bekam die Natur
genau das was sie braucht nämlich
leichten Landregen der zieht jetzt aber
über den Südosten ab und es wird schon
wieder trockener der Norden allerdings
bleibt in der Nähe der tiefdruckzentren
das bedeutet zum einen Höhenkaltluft in
der sich heute Nacht an den Küsten
zunehmend Schauer entwickeln zum anderen
frischt der Westwind stark auf mit
stürmischen Böden an der See außerdem
regnet es im Südosten leicht aber so
richtig viel ist das alles nicht morgen
schon gar nicht da gibt es anfangs an
den Alpen noch restriken an der Küste
weiter einige Schauer sonst wechseln
morgen Sonne und Wolken und es fällt
kaum mal ein Tropfen aber es wird windig
für alle vor allem an der See mit
stürmischen Böden bis Sturmböen aus West
die Temperaturen liegen in der Nacht
recht einheitlich zwischen 12 und 16
Grad morgen an der Küste bei 18 bis 20
sonst bei angenehmen 22 bis 26 Grad und
das ist auch die Spanne mit der ist in
der neuen Woche weitergeht
zudem bleibt es windig und immerhin für
die Natur immer mal wieder auch nass
teilweise mit Gewittern interessantes
heute noch mal ein Blick etwas weiter
der Temperatur Trend für Köln zeigt uns
nämlich dass das nächste Wochenende heiß
werden könnte mit über 30 Grad wir sind
gespannt und beobachten das für Sie
weiter